in this video I'll be talking about how
I made Hazel considerably faster and I'm
not just talking about in some kind of
isolated stress test but in an actual
game like in our latest ship game
dichotomy which by the way you can
download and play for free and Hazel
what's Hazel Hazel is my game engine
check it out if you want I'm going to
talk a little about why it was slow in
the first place and take you through
some history so buckle up there were
lots of little things here and there of
course but the main character was the
rendra like the entire renderer
basically needed to be Rewritten and
this was something I knew from pretty
much the beginning I'm going to try and
keep this like not too Technical and
give you kind of the high level picture
but if you are interested in the
technical details then I've actually
started this new thing on patreon for
the five dollar tier where I'm kind of
posting like these long form technical
videos where I just like hit record and
explain how things work without having
to like fit them into the format of a
YouTube video or anything like that so
if you want more details just check that
out so initially Hazel used opengl for
rendering in the very beginning and then
as time went on we added a Vulcan as an
API and I say added because there was a
time when Hazel supported both opengl
and Vulcan you could basically pick your
render API at runtime and the results
were pretty much identical like as in
visually you'd get the same set of
features now as time went on and more
and more kind of opengl devices were
like dropping off Vulcan was obviously
getting popularity Hardware was
progressing it made really no sense to
keep up in jail around especially
because we had no intention of like
supporting mobile devices our primary
kind of Target here is like desktop
Hardware at the moment and possibly
console Hardware in the future and
because of the way that Vulcan is to
really like take advantage of all of the
extra performance potential the Vulcan
like offers and why it was really
introduced in the first place you kind
of have to architect your entire
application to be like in that kind of
form like for example Vulcan supports
multi-threading on like a huge scale
whereas with opengl you can really
really just like spin off a render
thread if you want and usually that's
the best move of course and then kind of
have this just like two threaded system
where you have like a main thread and a
render thread that does like the opengl
API commands and that's kind of it like
you can't have like an extra resource
loading thread that has to be
incorporated into the render thread
somehow Vulcan also allows you to have
like many frames in Flight usually two
or three that just means that you can
get on with like the CPU part of like
rendering meaning submitting commands to
the GPU and like building up these
command buffers command lists while the
GPU is actually doing its rendering
because of course the GPU and the CPU
are two different devices so Vulcan
really just lets you take advantage of
that but if you want to take advantage
of that your engine has to be
architected in a way that does take
advantage of that and if you want to
support opengl and Vulcan simultaneously
you either need almost two different
engines not just two different renderers
really but two different engines
basically or you just cut opengl out
which is what we decided to do because
for the reasons I've described as well
as being a small team with not many
resources it doesn't make sense for us
to support opengl so a long story short
because we did support both of them that
there's a lot written kind of in a way
that has to support opengl that I never
really got around to rewriting and
because of that the CPU usage on
particularly the render thread was
extremely high in Hazel and it really
did not scale well at all and there were
lots of little reasons as to why it was
slow but really at the end of the day it
came down to one big reason and it's
crazy how like this one huge chunk of
the puzzle just ended up like affecting
so much and like the performance
Improvement we've seen from it has like
just been absolutely brilliant and that
was the way that we were handling these
things called descriptor sets involved
him you know what else is brilliant the
value of this video is sponsored by
brilliant.org those of you who don't
know what brilliant.org is it's an
amazing website filled with lots and
lots of Great Courses on various stem
topics me personally I love brilliant
for its mouth courses it starts all the
way in the beginning with the Everyday
Math course which is fantastic if you've
always been kind of scared of math and
you just don't know how how to start
it's so confusing to you or if you're
struggling with the more advanced topics
you know like calculus for example
brilliant can really really help you
there because Brilliance courses are
extremely engaging and interactive they
present these complex topics visually
they let you play with the actual
numbers and see the results visually
using these widgets the lessons are
organized into like really nice kind of
bite-sized chunks and they'll quiz you
to engage you and to make sure that
you're actually retaining this
information brilliant have a 30-day free
trial that you can check out to see what
they offer for yourselves and if you do
go on to like it then brilliant have
been nice enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
just go to brilliant.org the channel
link will be in the description below
huge thank you as always to brilliant
for sponsoring this video by the way
check out this thing Discord sent me
what I do with this now as I mentioned I
don't want to get too deep here on a
technical level but I'll try my best to
kind of summarize this so that it may
kind of make sense basically there are
these things called resources is that
too deep when you write code that you're
going to execute on your GPU such as
like in the form of a render pass or a
compute Trader you'll probably need to
use things like buffers or textures and
so when you write your Shader you have
the ability to kind of take in inputs of
resources you want to use such as
buffers or textures and you can also
kind of output to those resources as
well really if we boil this down it's
kind of like I just want to use this
memory like I'd like to read from or
write to that memory and the way that
shaders are written these are kind of
expressed as just like binding points
meaning like I want to use this texture
and it's going to be at binding point
two it's kind of like an idea that lets
you address that particular resource
that's going to be bound in that
pipeline now fundamentally the way that
this works is actually kind of similar
in opengl and in Vulcan but in opengl
everything was kind of reactive meaning
that like right before before you issue
a draw call or like a computer dispatch
you can just be like hey I'm binding
this texture to slot 2. and that's that
now in Vulcan it almost works the same
way it's just that there's this new type
of resource that is used to describe
resources themselves and that's called a
descriptor and these descriptors are
organized into different descriptor sets
and so the idea is you have like this
little like piece of memory on the GPU
itself that kind of contains like almost
a description if you want to call it
that of a resource that you can then
bind to a particular binding point and
the idea is because that's kind of
fundamentally stored in vram that kind
of descriptor you can create these like
sets of descriptors up front and then
kind of bind them in bulk before you do
any kind of like rendering or compute
work and another major advantage is
because there's like more than one
descriptor set meaning like a group of
descriptors you can actually organize
these based on like frequency of change
and not really frequency of change like
you know I need to update date my camera
buffer every frame but more like I need
to find a completely different resource
and so you can get a bit more deep into
this like you could for example have
different descriptor sets for like per
draw like resources such as like this is
my material with all of my like you know
PBR inputs like my Albedo map my normal
map metalness roughness textures all of
that kind of stuff versus things like
the camera buffer which are kind of
global like probably for the whole frame
even not just for that render pass but
anyway all of that aside the point is
there's lots you can do in welcome that
you can't do in open jail but we were
still living in the opengl days because
we supported opengl as well and we
started with opengl so now that opengl
was gone we just had Vulcan kind of
playing that part of the rendering game
like opengl did and that is basically
what this new render Rod changed it
basically rewrote the whole like
renderer resource management system I
created these things called render
passes which inside Hazel it kind of
lets you take in a set of inputs and
produces a set of output resources which
you can then bind like you can take
outputs from some render passes bind
them to inputs of different render
passes and so you basically create
something called a render graph now
currently I wouldn't say we're quite at
the stage of it actually being organized
into a graph which can be really useful
because you can automatically like
handle dependencies between passes such
as like a shadow map pass outputting a
depth buffer that needs to be used as an
input in like your normal kind of
geometry pass but it's on the way to
that and even without it being organized
into a graph per se it's still a huge
benefit because it lets us kind of
declare statically kind of all of our
render passes and compute passes wire in
all of the inputs and the outputs and we
do that like up front it's kind of like
we declare that the scene renderer that
needs to render the scene this is like
the complete list of render passes all
the inputs that are needed for each
render pass all of the outputs that plug
into like other render pass inputs and
that's kind of it it's all like done up
front and if stuff does change which can
happen so if you like resize the window
for example it has to recreate a whole
bunch of stuff of not just like the main
frame buffers for every single pass
pretty much but also like some like
storage buffers need to be resized like
for light culling for example because
the number of tiles on the screen may
have changed there's lots of like little
things that need to change and since
you're recreating those resources like
images and buffers those descriptors
have to be updated but Hazel handles all
that automatically when it's needed it's
also further Complicated by the fact
that there are multiple frames in Flight
meaning that like for a lot of these
like uniform buffers like there may need
to be more than one of them and you need
to make sure that you use the correct
one based on the frame index so like on
a typical Nvidia GPU there are three
frames in Flight which means we
basically need three copies of that of
those buffers then you also have
materials which might get updated but
you can't update descriptor sets that
are currently being used on the GPU for
rendering right now because the CPU and
the GPU are running kind of concurrently
which means that the GPU is using that
descriptor set you can't update it from
the CPU so suddenly you need you need to
have several like descriptor sets kind
of per frame in flight so that you can
safely update them and then you just
bind the one for that frame index before
you render so there are lots of nuances
which I will discuss in that in-depth
video on my patreon and that's also a
really good place to kind of ask
questions and I'll probably end up
making follow-up videos to that if
people are interested but basically
that's kind of like how the new system
works I'll just show some code on screen
as well just to give you an example of
like what it means to like declare like
a render pass and Define a render pass I
guess up front and yeah that kind of
stuff just happens on like the creation
of the center Endra so basically like on
Startup and then we're able to like
validate that render pass to make sure
that all the inputs have been satisfied
and then we're able to bake that render
pass which basically just means it will
allocate the descriptor sets from the
descriptor pool and actually like tie
the the resources into those descriptor
sets so that they can be used now to
quickly contrast this to how it was done
before there was basically like kind of
one descriptor pull I guess per frame in
Flight globally we reset it at the start
of every frame and we just allocated
descriptor sets from scratch every
single frame and then updated those
descriptor sets to bind the resources
and because there was only one set
because opengl only supports one set
right so there was only like set equals
zero like that's all you had everything
was in that one set it meant that every
single draw call when you want to draw
something with a material it basically
had to allocate a descriptor set and
then every single input into that Shader
like everything from per draw stuff like
the Albedo texture for example to like
the camera buffer and like you know the
light storage buffers and all of that
stuff those descriptors had to be set up
from scratch every single frame so even
though like allocating descriptor sets
from a pool is not like the slowest
thing it's not that bad when you do have
it for like per draw basically for like
an entire 3D scene and there are several
render passes it's just like it's it
really is quite a bit of CPU overhead so
that's kind of just gone now which is
amazing and to show you kind of the
performance Improvement that we've seen
main I want to introduce you to a new
member of the studio Channel family is
this a weird shot
right so I want to introduce you guys to
the newest member of the studio Channel
family
we have this beautiful
pre-built computer actually you know
what you can share this special moment
with me
so this is the studio Channel QA PC this
is like this steam Hardware survey
computer like I went on Steam Hardware
survey the latest one March 2023 and I
basically like got a computer that had
the exact specs so an Intel 6 core CPU I
don't even know which one this actually
is I'll put on the screen 16 gigabytes
of RAM and RTX 3060 which I think it
used to be a 1650 was like the number
one GPU by far but now somehow in March
2023 it's changed the RTX 3060 so that's
what's in here and the idea is we have
like kind of like the most popular
configuration like just your stock
standard average PC as far as Steam goes
and that's gonna basically be used for
just like testing Hazel like both just
making sure that it builds and every
commit Builds on like all the available
platforms and also that like performance
is kind of stable or getting better so
the idea is eventually to run automated
tests on this computer so that like
every command obviously doesn't have to
be manually checked and this fella over
here will be the computer doing that
testing all right so here we are on the
QA machine really need a name for this
computer
Poppy
we're gonna call her poppy so here we
have poppy as you can see it's a
Absolutely Fresh install like I I
haven't even bothered to install any
other browser we're just Microsoft
edging um and I've got two versions of
dichotomy here we've got the new
renderer version and the old version
Let's uh rearrange them so let's take a
look at the old version now this is
basically like the the version that we
shipped this like this version that's on
hio which by the way you guys can
download like for free and you know play
our game it's basically the same there
are a few modifications just like some
extra key commands that do some stuff
which we'll find out in a minute uh if
we go into here and just launch
dichotomy by the way since we'll be
mostly focusing on the CPU usage I have
this little app here called Sizer which
is pretty cool it basically lets you
resize like the last selected window to
whatever resolution you want such a
640x480 and the reason why I'm doing
this is because we want to basically
exclude like GPU usage from this
obviously the more pixels you have like
the more processing the GPU will have to
do and even though the GPU will be the
one doing that work the CPU might have
to wait for the GPU to finish before it
can progress which will affect like the
total kind of frame time anyway if we
just uh hit enter to play control F3
even on the retail kind of version the
shipped copy brings up these stats and
you can see that we have like you know I
mean straight away you can kind of look
at the render thread and see that it's
spending about three milliseconds now
keep in mind this like dodgy looking GPU
timer which sometimes goes to zero for
some reason in this version that is also
taking up like a bit of time if I make
this even smaller it's a little bit hard
to see now but you can see the GPU time
is a lot kind of faster and the render
thread time which potentially includes
waiting for the GPU as well is also kind
of smaller but you can still see it's
like around two milliseconds sometimes
spiking up to three or so and we've
really reduced the GPU time from this as
well now what I've done is I've made F2
spawn these kind of dead bodies uh and
the reason why is just because I want to
increase the like amount of objects that
we have to process now you can see the
render thread has increased quite a bit
even though the GPU time is still kind
of constant because we're not really
increasing much GPU usage here but we
are as you can see increasing the random
thread usage if I just take a screenshot
of that and go into paint all right so
here we have a screenshot if we talk
about this a little bit let me explain
some of these numbers in a bit more
detail so the most important part is
probably this like these bottom two
timers because these are the kind of
overall frame times this is like the
overall time spent by the GPU like for
that frame and then this is the kind of
complete frame time so you could look at
it as the CPU frame time because that's
what it is but it that does potentially
also include if we have to wait for the
GPU to finish its kind of processing
because obviously we can't necessarily
continue on within X CPU frame if the
GPU is too far behind we have to wait
for it to catch up so 3.34 milliseconds
is what also contributes you can see to
this frame rate now you can see though
that if we look at the distribution of
work there are two different threads we
have the main thread which is 1.75
milliseconds this includes things like
script update and physics as well all
the physics simulation as well as you
know just like well the whole entire
Logic for the game and everything the
engine has to do including render thread
submission commands so basically what I
mean by that is the main thread tells
the render thread what to do by queuing
up work onto a render command queue and
then when the main thread has finished
its frame it kicks off the render thread
so it starts going through that queue
while simultaneously at the same time
the main thread is building up the next
frames render command Q so it's kind of
like a double buffered cue the fact that
these are two different threads is
obviously really good for performance
because it means that instead of the
frame time being like the sum of 1.75
and 3.3 it's 3.34 it's basically like
whatever takes longer which is this guy
since they're running at the same time
this isn't like added together and
therefore like five milliseconds is our
frame time is 3.3 which is great however
you can also see that there's like time
timers are it's hard to get an exact
reading because they're kind of almost
referencing different frames but you can
see that the GPU time is around 2
milliseconds 2.25 milliseconds the
render thread time is a whole
millisecond more than that and to make
matters worse it's kind of difficult to
see in this version of Hazel well with
the timers that I've exposed here how
much of this time is actually pure kind
of CPU usage because what it could be is
it could have finished its work in about
one millisecond and it could be waiting
2.25 milliseconds for the GPU to finish
the frame because the GPU is too far
behind so technically speaking this
could be as low as one millisecond of
actual work but let me just cheat a
little bit and tell you that it's not
it's about three milliseconds of actual
work and maybe I'll share some like more
specific examples with you because Tim
has been working on designing QA tests
specifically to stress test different
parts of the engine so that we can
really kind of show this new renderer
just massively improving the CPU usage
but on the other hand like stress tests
are good in a way but also I feel like
real world examples are probably better
which is why I'm showing you like an
actual game rather than like you know
here's a million objects here's a stress
test that's probably not never gonna
happen in the real world I think both
both are necessary so anyway my point is
that the render thread here is taking
around three milliseconds we're just
going to take that at face value three
milliseconds Let's uh close this and
let's take a look at the new renderer
version of dichotomy so I have actually
a few different binaries here I've built
one with screen space Reflections off I
think they're on in this version it's
kind of hard to tell uh just because
that's going to reduce the GPU usage and
even though that is technically a
configuration setting that you can set
outside of recompiling the binary I've
recorded binary and then we have a more
timers version
um which is actually the one that I'm
going to run
this was something that I just realized
it why not add more timers so that we
can see a few more kind of interesting
things so if we launch this so this is
the new version right so if we launch
this you can see some interesting timers
uh first of all the frame rate in
general is higher right and if I make
this like tiny kind of like I did before
let me just try and make it like roughly
the same size which will be difficult
just to kind of reduce that GPU usage
you can see we're like comfortably above
500 FPS here and we have some
interesting stats here as well so let me
just spawn in like some more
in our bodies try and make it kind of
fair so it's about the same amount all
right let's grab a screenshot and to
make this super clear we have old and we
have new so if we take a look at these
stats so first of all like right like
clear performance Improvement and by the
way when you're down to this level
meaning like these are both running very
fast right like we're above 300 FPS and
obviously like the resolution is small
but if we increase the resolution it's
obviously not going to increase the CPU
usage just like the GPU usage so we are
in like kind of like a very fast
territory here the amount that you're
going to see like increase is obviously
going to be smaller like to double the
fps to go from like 330 to 660 like
you're really kind of going from like
3.34 milliseconds to like I don't know
1.6 or 1.7 which is
very difficult to do because you're in
that kind of millisecond range like it's
obviously hard to process and render
this entire game in such a fast frame
rate but you can see the new Hazel's
actually able to do that this is
substantially faster the GPU time is
also a little bit faster and there are
reasons for that it's because I've cut
out some of the render passes that
weren't even used in this version but
shipped anyway like stuff that was kind
of in use by the editor but you can see
the render thread is also much much much
faster and in fact what's cool here is
that we actually have a breakdown of
what the render thread is doing so the
CPU only time here is 0.98 milliseconds
that's really important to note because
what that does is it cuts out any time
we spend waiting for the GPU so you can
see the GPU took 1.95 milliseconds we
spent about 0.8 milliseconds waiting for
the GPU because we couldn't progress
further so that's what kind of builds up
that 1.77 milliseconds but really the
render thread itself the CPU time of
just the render thread operations that
it had to do was around 1 a second and
then it also spent about half a
millisecond waiting for the main thread
because you can see the main thread for
this like particular frame for whatever
reason is taking up more time than the
render thread and obviously the main
thread is not waiting for the render
thread because it's taking longer and by
the way if you're interested in this
kind of main thread render thread kind
of thing I did make a video talking
about multi-threading and Hazel that was
actually the first devlog so I'll have
that linked up there you can take a look
at that on the first episode of the
devlog series not like the first devlog
ever for Hazel and if people want more
depth then I did mention I'm trying to
do that on patreon now so like leave a
comment there but that 0.98 milliseconds
is basically all the all the work that's
been submitted to the random command
queue which a lot of it is just like
Vulcan commands so like stuff like
recording Vulcan command buffers that's
what's there right so that's the kind of
stuff we're doing there and obviously in
the old version it was still doing that
stuff but it was also doing like you
know allocating descriptor sets and
doing updating descriptor sets doing all
this extra CPU work not to mention the
Hazel side of like gathering information
about materials and all the buffers and
textures and resources it used all of
that stuff was happening every frame
it's now no longer happening unless it
needs to so because something's changed
and the result is something much much
faster now this game is fairly light in
terms of CPU usage which is again why
it's difficult to demonstrate this we
just haven't made a particularly heavy
game and this obviously these numbers
are on this like QA machine it's on what
do we call it poppy it's not unlike some
it's not on my like development rig
which is way more powerful this is like
the steam Hardware survey PC so yeah
that's uh what we've been up to I
actually kind of started this journey
back in October I think October or
November so it has definitely been a
long time I haven't spent that much time
on it but I would say it probably did
take me at least a solid four weeks of
work like if I had to add up all the
bits here and there that I've actually
spent working on this new renderer I
would say at least four weeks four to
six weeks maybe even so it definitely
has been like a lot of work but I'm very
excited that we finally done this
because this doesn't even really
demonstrate the difference too well I'm
really looking forward to seeing some of
those stress tests because I know that
like you know the more objects you have
the more materials you have it kind of
increases that cost will just increase
kind of linearly if not even probably a
bit more than linearly whereas with this
new system it just scales a lot better
like you can have so many more objects
so many more materials and you won't
even really feel that cost too much
which is obviously really cool anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this video Studio
channel is doing a game Jam at the end
of this month we're doing a lot of Dev
53 I think it is and we'll be using this
new renderer obviously for that which is
I'm super excited that I actually could
finish this in time because I was
getting slightly stressed we'll all be
live streaming that game Jam for the
entire three days so make sure you catch
us there if you have any questions about
this new renderer you want to see more
kind of Vulcan rendering related videos
then definitely let me know in the
comment section below don't forget to
check out brilliant.org channel as well
and I will see you next time goodbye